jetzt könnte leben in die bude kommen
die ersten katholischen pfarrer bekennen
sich auch zum schwulsein reaktion hieß
authentisch für eine kirche ohne angst
aber während eine kirche ohne angst
überhaupt noch die katholische kirche es
wäre endlich die katholische kirche wenn
man sich die die anzahl der schwulen
priester weg denkt aus der katholischen
kirche ich glaube dann könnten wir
dichtmachen
[Musik]
ich finde wir brauchen ganz neue töne
denn diese kirche fluten ob als priester
oder kardinal
und in den vatikan zu reformieren wäre
eine transport
[Musik]
das hat richtig was fürs herz werden
darf denn jetzt heiraten mir ist es auf
einigen ebenen es ist doch ganz
verständlich männlich weiblich gerne den
katholiken ist die ehe sakrament das
funktioniert nur zwischen männlich und
weiter einen kombi nähere personen eine
weibliche das ist ja keine
gleichgeschlechtliche ehe aber das ist
echt herausfordernd so also wir machen
hier mal ein fragezeichen hier dann auch
nehme ich mal würde ich auch frage ist
ja und dann werde jetzt noch die sonder
frage was wäre denn jetzt wenn wir eine
männliche person hätten die einen
zizmann ist und einen mann der einen
trans mann ist wäre das dann wieder
möglich
das überfordert mich aber zwei fragen
hätten wir noch wofür sind sie im
freundeskreis öfters schief angeguckt
worden für das schwulsein oder fürs
katholisch sein dann mittlerweile eher
fürs katholisch sein und vor allem fürs
arbeiten in der katholischen kirche
können sie sich unter diesen umständen
vorstellen in absehbarer zeit noch einen
zweiten homosexuellen einzustellen aber
wir haben eine ganze reihe davon also
wir sind da relativ offen warum glauben
sie wird es die erste päpstin vielleicht
geben 23 24 25
welches
die basis der katholischen kirche ist in
ordnung aber was darüber ist je spitzer
das wird umso beschissener ist die
katholiken die meisten waren die
schlimmsten die kirche beten hintergehen
sind in diesem sinne wir sehen uns dann
demnächst wahrscheinlich in der hölle
wie alle menschen die wenn wir mit allen
menschen jesus nie wenn der liebt allah
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und stehe ich richtig super also dann
los
liebe fans der feinsten unterhaltung
klickt hier hin wenn ihr weitere videos
sehen wollt
das war super trägt wir haben es euch
sie auch echt clique aus heute